Let's answer this together.
To answer it, I'm just going to review the 3 rules that talk about these trees.
All of the left children of a node are less than or equal to it,
all of the right children of a node are greater than or equal to it,
and both of the children should follow rules I through III as well.
This is a recursive data structure.
Let's take a look at this first option here on the left. What could go in this box?
Well, since it's a right child of this node labeled 1, by rule number II
we know that it has to be greater than or equal to 1.
And since it's eventually reachable on the left from 3,
we know that it's less than or equal to 3.
So the only things I could put in this box are 1, 2, or 3--not 7.
It can't hold 7 because it has to be less than or equal to 3.
So this one won't work out for us.
By this same sort of reasoning--let's take a look at this box--
we know it has to be greater than or equal to 3 because it's to the right of this 3 node
but less than or equal to 5.
So 4 would be a great thing to put there, but 7 doesn't fit.
Down here we're getting a little bit closer.
This node has to be less than or equal to 6
but also greater than or equal to 5.
This is a little harder to see in the picture,
but starting from 5's right child I can eventually get down here.
This is greater than or equal to 5.
So maybe 5.5 could go in there but not 7.
Over here--oh, I'm getting excited now--
since I can reach it going to the left of 8,
I need something less than or equal to 8 and something greater than or equal to 6.
7 seems like a perfect thing to put here, so I could definitely add 7 to this part of my tree.
Both of these would have to be greater than or equal to 8,
so they're not good answers for 7.
Now let's take a look at this evil box up here at the top.
We've been describing trees with exactly 2 branches.
We've been talking about the left child and the right child.
I drew this mysterious third branch coming off of 5,
and I drew it in the picture to the right, so you might be tempted to think,
"Oh, this has to be a little better than 5 and a little less than 8, so 7 would be perfect."
But in fact, the sort of recursive data structure we're describing
allows exactly or up to 2 children.
So it would be very tempting to put a 7 there,
but that's not the kind of data structure we're describing.
Now, don't feel bad if this one seemed very tempting to you.
It's entirely possible to make trees like this that have 3 children every time
or a variable number of children every time.
But the practice problems I'm going to be going over
require 1, 0, or 2.